hello again uber nerd fans I heard you
blew up the Twittersphere about my sweet
new feature film the Lego Batman movie
you know it's kind of like the original
lego movie only vastly superior because
it revolves entirely around me so anyway
when you're as super as me you don't get
just one trailer you get two trailers in
one week check this out
[Music]
hi mom hey Dad
I saved the city again today
I think you would have been really brown
hey Alfred I am so sorry I have
incredible reflexes I should have known
better than to sneak up on him like that
were you looking at the old family
pictures again no I wasn't sir I've seen
you go through similar phases in 2016 in
2012 and 2008 and 2005 in 1997 in 1995
and 1992 with 1989 and that weird one in
1966 I have aged phenomenally do you
want to talk about how you're feeling
what no I don't want to do that sir
no sir no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no gosh I hope
we were recording that we're not Alfred
what did I say a B are always be
recording
[Music]
I'm Batman I'll be bad 2008 I'm Batman